ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
[音楽]
戦況下はうるせえなぁ
日本語失業とタイの中井
電車に乗っているとき周りにいる日本人は絶対につまりに座ってこない
どうしたらいいですか外国人あるあるの減少ですね
良い解決策あるかなり大変だけど毎日者を浴びてデオドラントもつける事
仕方がない
にはいつも akb how というふうに訳されていますこれ以外の訳を教えて
ください
またこの質問会仕方ねぇなまあ例えば
初心者にとっての最も効果的な日本語を勉強方法を教えてください anime
hentai ev 以外にということだと思うけど
anime hentai e 具イーグに何か勉強方法だパッケ新言語
例はについてと思いますかこれだけ本音で答える
昔ながらの伝統的な日本語に基づいた非常に美しい
ネーミングセンスだと思う日本語を勉強する動機付けばなかなか見つかりませんどうし
たらいいですか
字幕が
アンカラ吹き替え場に変えること日本語ってなんでこんなに複雑なの
全く同じ意味を持つ言葉ってありすぎだろ
全く同じ意味を持つ言葉なんてない全く同じ意味を持つと編んだか勘違いしている言葉
をたくさんあるだろうけど
1年間日本に留学しましたがその後帰国しました
できたら日本で仕事をしたい
ですが海外から elt 以外の職人道を応募したらいいですか
alt 以外の職どんどこ今度 alt になるんですが
新人 lt 向けの助言ってありますかいいか初めて出会った女性と交際しないこと
その人の panic at the disco 大きくとしても灯すのバブル
チーズバーガーを食べ過ぎないこと
50代のクラスメイトに敬語を使う必要
ってありますかないマンタか60代であればっていう前提ですか
相づちを打つという習慣に泣かなくなりません
打たなかったらどうなりますか
というような感じになる日本の家に泊まるときに何かやるべき事ってありますか
素晴らしいお土産を買って言ってそれをつまらないものだと言って渡すこと
日本語を話すときにその暴飲をいつも鼻を抜けて甲高い声で言っちゃいますなんだか
まるでアニメの主人公みたいに
これって普通ですかこのように話したら
なるとか好きすぎる15歳のアニメオタクに聞こえませんか
心配しなくて良いこれは普通弾なぜかって言って俺たち外国人はみんな
なるとが好きすぎる用地のアニメオタクだからだん
ni